if there's one thing that we New Yorkers
hold dear its our bagels but I live in
LA now and the bagels aren't horrible so
what is it about in New York bagel are
they really that much better than LA
bagels is it the recipe the water is it
just plain nostalgia why came to the
bagel broker in LA to find out
what specific qualities should someone
look for in a great bagel the first
experience should be a nice good crunch
and she gets softer and softer as you
get to the middle of the day and the
ingredients and the flavor is a big
thing that you gotta work with a lot of
people would say that la bagels not as
good as New York bagels that would be a
statement made by New Yorkers but I
think it's just an engrained in New
Yorkers heads from when they were
children that bagels are New York and
pizzas New York nothing compares to test
this theory I mean you got six bagels I
picked up LA bagels from the bagel group
Noah's New York bagels and Sam's fake
Scott the last of the LA bagels then I
have bagels shipped from my child's at
bagel place bagel boss in New York now
six New Yorkers are going to see if they
could choose the New York bagel Who am I
looking at here that aesthetically is
very pleasing to me but I realize it's
just melted cheese on top what kind of a
weird texture it should be a very tiny
hole here but the fact that I can see
through both of these like eye goggles
not good not New York bagel you can
smell the jalapeno so this one I like a
lot of cream cheese don't you to my
grandma that's a nice healthy schmear of
cream cheese how's LA bagel written all
over it I'm am eating it but it's not
decorated it's edible but it's not New
York agreed 100% agree but I do want
okay what so these are shriveled are
these cranberries and rye seeds or
something the whole here is a lot of
elyon see I can't really put my finger
through it that time it seems like the
New York bagel is something that like
really can't be good you know I don't
know that they're about introducing new
kooky flavors oh my god even trying to
rip it apart is awful it feels cold and
sad I feel cold in my pink soul do you
think it's a New York bagel oh man I
don't know I feel like I have to taste
all of them and then miss I know you
seem very la to me just look at it and
know that it was me
I don't think this is a New York bagel
why are you eating more of it oh because
I'm upset this is an egg bagel and this
is definitely a New York bagel right
what see how see how why this is this is
what a New York bagel is these raisins
are weird it's got that fluffy feel to
it you can smell it from afar different
colored reasons I don't know this
reminds me of breaking fast at Yom
Kippur it's better better the flavor of
the of the seeds are definitely coming
through afters and aftertaste actually
tastes pretty good though their density
it's alive I'm choking up it's so good
I'm gonna lean towards New York I don't
know that the raisins alone will make me
say like no it's for my legs I'm not
ready to say that this is from me from
New York though it makes me homesick for
New York I miss New York really badly
this one looks promising I'm suddenly
doubting everything I said about the
other bagels this is it I can just feel
my tie together look at that together
those raisins look normal and I like the
swirl sighs okay squishiness see small
holes there's like no comparison it's
got the look it's got the feel there's
something just a little bit off that I
can't put my finger on none of these are
really like jumping out of me as the
bagel of my childhood I really thought
the one before was a New York bagel but
this could be a New York bagel as well
but it might be an imposter what I'm
saying is that the last bagel is an Eric
bagel this swirl is telling me something
I'm gonna have to go with the last one
to number three
yeah I've notice over three threes a New
York bagel I'm going with three please
tell me I'm right come on rs4
oh my god I know my grandmother's
turning over her grave
what happened to it and travel myth I
like bagels just aren't the same when
you're eating a New York bagel you just
know mm-hmm
you just know